ja 14 Uhr da lädt der Kanzler Vertreter
aus der Wirtschaft der Wissenschaft und
der Bundesbank und den Gewerkschaften
ins Kanzleramt zum Krisengipfel der
große Krisengipfel mitten in der
Sommerpause und unsere Reporterin Kira
Ortmann ist jetzt schon vor Ort ja Kira
was steht da denn heute alles wichtiges
auf der Tagesordnung
er tatsächlich ist natürlich die
Gaskrise das ganz zentrale Thema heute
hier es werden auch Themen wie die
corona-krise noch mal besprochen aber
die Gaskrise ist natürlich das worum es
hier im Moment geht vor allen Dingen
soll eben die Kommunikation zwischen
Bund und Ländern thematisiert werden
denn die ist laut Union zumindest im
Moment sehr schlecht im Moment möchte
man eben sich darauf konzentrieren dass
man die Wirtschaft unterstützen kann
dass man die Bevölkerung aber auch vor
allem natürlich unterstützen kann wie
man eben mit dieser Gaskrise umgeht und
insgesamt vier Fragen stehen dabei ganz
zentral im Mittelpunkt und zwar die
erste ist wie viel Gas muss Deutschland
einsparen falls Russland nach den
Wartungen der Pipelines die Gaslieferung
komplett aushält das ist ja gerade das
ganz aktuelle Thema das Putin eben
dieser eine Pipeline gestoppt hat wegen
der Wartungen ihr habt das gerade schon
gesagt und jetzt eben abzuwarten ist ob
er diese wirklich wieder im Betrieb
nimmt wir haben es vorhin auch von
Robert Habeck schon gehört dass er eben
gesagt hat das kann sein dass es eben
nicht dazu kommt Putin bzw Russland es
eben ausnutzt jetzt den deutschen das
Gas abzuschalten weil Deutschland eben
die Ukraine im Krieg so sehr unterstützt
die zweite Frage ist welche Konzepte hat
die Bundesregierung bereits vorbereitet
um im Ernstfall signifikante Gasmengen
einzusparen das ist natürlich etwas wo
rüber die Politiker in den letzten Tagen
auch die ganze Zeit schon gesprochen
haben dass wir jetzt alle sparen müssen
die dritte Frage wie können
Genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigt
werden damit Betriebe ihre
Feuerungsanlagen von Gas auf Kohle und
Öl und Holz umstellen können und wie
hoch sind die Gasmengen die über
Ersatzlieferungen nach Deutschland
gebracht werden können dazu haben wir
uns gestern den Bau eines neuen
lng-terminals zum Beispiel an der Ostsee
angeschaut das allerdings auch erst im
Dezember im Betrieb genommen wird und da
muss man jetzt eben abwarten was wir bis
Dezember und vor allen Dingen dann auch
in die kommenden Monaten ja machen
können um eben mehr Gas hier in
Deutschland zu bekommen nicht von
Russland
du verfolgst den Krisengipfel im
Kanzleramt für uns vor Ort vielen Dank
für den Moment Kira Ortmann
ja und die Frage wollen wir direkt
weitergeben Gazprom hat der verlauten
lassen dass nach Ende der Wartung von
nordstream 1 dann heute in einer Woche
kein Gas mehr fließen könnte das keine
gegebenenfalls nicht gewährleistet
werden so die Formulierung darüber
sprechen wir jetzt mit dem ehemaligen
russischen Premierminister Mikael
kassianow Herr kassianow was denken sie
wird bald wieder Gas fließen oder nicht
aus politischer Sicht möchte Putin
natürlich sehr gern und der hat auch
schon die Entscheidung getroffen die
Gaslieferung einzustellen er ist wütend
er ist enttäuscht
enttäuscht auch weil er sehr viele Jahre
darauf verwendet hat oh man wirklich
loyale Beziehungen der deutschen Elite
zu erreichen deutschen Wirtschafts Elite
zu erreichen dass alle seinem Regime
gegenüber Royal sind und jetzt passiert
das was er wirklich nicht erwartet hat
nämlich dass Deutschland
und auch der Europäischen Union
Frankreich und so weiter haben einen
negatives Bild dessen gezeichnet zu
Recht aus Putin in der Ukraine tut und
er hat nicht erwartet dass es zu solchen
Sanktionen kommen sechs Pakete schon
dass die Russische Föderation so davon
betroffen ist und er wollte und will
natürlich jetzt Deutschland dafür
bestrafen aber ich denke ich vermute
das technisch dieses System gerade das
Gas
sicherlich eine Waffe ist in seinen
Händen in potienten und er ist
sicherlich bereit diese Waffe jetzt
einzusetzen dass die Lieferung
eingestellt werden jetzt im Sommer
glaube ich werden sie zwar wieder
aufgenommen aber diese Frage kann im
Herbst wieder auftauchen dass er dann
eine spätestens im Herbst die
Gasversorgung für Deutschland komplett
einstellt aber er kann auf das macht ja
irgendwie auch keinen Sinn dieses
Psychospielchen warum sagt er denn nicht
gleich okay es gibt einfach kein Gas
mehr und wie abhängig ist Russland
eigentlich auch von unserem Geld
aber auch technologisch also sie können
jetzt nicht einfach Ihre
Förderquellen schließen das Gas muss
hier raus aus dem Boden es muss ja
irgendwie abgesetzt werden also ich
glaube das ist gar nicht so einfach sehr
einfach zu konservieren diese
gastförderstätten das kostet sehr viel
Geld du bin ich kein gasexpertin gerade
was die Technologie der Förderung angeht
aber es ist ja ganz klar sie können
jetzt nicht einfach einfach die Ventile
zudrehen und sagen dann kommt nichts
mehr raus das geht nicht also insofern
sind sie auch abhängig sie bereiten sich
möglicherweise darauf vor wie Förderung
einzustellen aber ich glaube nicht dass
das jetzt im Juli passiert im Juli für
das Gas weiterlaufen ist das nur Auftakt
Herr kassianow oder was könnte noch
kommen was könnte uns noch drohen
dieses Hybriden Krieges für diese Krieg
läuft ja auch schon das ist eine
Maßnahme die jetzt in diesem Hybriden
Krieg vorgenommen wurde und die kann
sich in der Zukunft durchaus vorsetzen
diese Maßnahmenpaket aber insofern
wundert mich das nicht viel da kann man
jetzt noch erwarten es könnte passieren
dass
Cyberangriffe geführt werden und die
sind ja bereits geführt worden in der
Vergangenheit in den Ostsee an einer
Staaten in den praktischen Staaten
insofern ist die Palette eine sehr breit
gefächerte
natürlich ist Putin jetzt sehr nervöse
und seinen Umfeld auch die haben gar
nicht erwartet mit welcher einheitlichen
transatlantischen Reaktion der Westen
der vorstellig geworden ist dass der
Westen bereit ist nicht nur die
europäische Freiheit sondern auch in der
Ukraine die Freiheit zu verteidigen und
es ist tatsächlich so dass in der
Ukraine die Freiheit Europas der
baltischen Staaten und andere Staaten
aus Europas ver
diese Gedanken diese Absichten Putins zu
unterbinden muss man jetzt handeln damit
sowas im 21 Jahrhundert nicht möglich
ist Herr Casino wir reden viel darüber
was diesen Krieg zuspitzen und auch
verlängern könnte gibt es denn
irgendetwas aus ihrer Sicht sie kennen
ja auch Vladimir Putin gut was den Krieg
beenden könnte was Putin dazu bewegen
könnte diesen Krieg zu beenden endlich
das ist ein ganz anderer Putin ein
anderer als der den ich damals kannte
das war vor 20 Jahren heute hat er sich
sehr gewandelt ein Mensch der wenn man
so will alle Masken von sich gerissen
hat sich gar nicht mehr
ich kann nicht mehr verstecken will und
wirklich zeigte er ist ein KGB-Offizier
und diese demokratischen Prinzipien die
er auf den Lippen geführt hat in den
90er Jahren in 2000er Jahren sind im
vollkommen egal ein ganz anderer Putin
den wir jetzt den an aggressiver Mensch
mit einer kgb-mentalität der für alles
erscheint für alles jetzt bereit ist
alles zu tun
wie ein armee-general sozusagen der
der jetzt auf dem gefäßfeld sterben will
ist er natürlich nicht nein er möchte
nicht sterben für seine Sache er möchte
provozieren er möchte gefahren
aufschwören und er möchte versuchen
natürlich seine Ziele zu erreichen dass
für ihn dann zu einem positiven
die Szenarien die sich jetzt so
entwickeln ging ganz sein Vorstellungen
zu wieder insofern kann man ihn nur
besiegen wenn die Ukraine besiegt
Ukraine also der Sieg der Ukraine wäre
ein Sieg über das Putin Regime und
Ukraine fällt wenn die Ukraine verliert
wird die Aggression woanders fortgeführt
in der Ukraine woanders in Moldau dann
in den baltischen Staaten insofern muss
man sagen dass das geopolitische
Schicksal der nächsten Jahrzehnte heute
entscheiden wird also ein sehr wichtige
historische Zeit die wir jetzt erleben
sie leben aus Sicherheitsgründen im Exil
haben sie Kontakt zu anderen Russen die
ebenfalls wie sie im Exil leben
die sowohl in Russland leben also unsere
politische Partei sie ist natürlich
nicht mehr einflussreiche Momente aber
Leute sind nach wie vor dort aber ich
habe auch Kontakte mit Leuten die
außerhalb Russlands Leben so wie ich die
also wegen des Krieges das Land
verlassen haben
wir
kommunizieren miteinander tauschen über
unsere Meinungen aus unsere Einschätzung
über die Lage im Land
besten Dank für das Gespräch und dass
sie Zeit für uns hatten danke schön
sehr gern vielen Dank